Speaker 1: It is great to welcome to the program
today, Heidi Bogosian, who's in New York City
based attorney and author, whose latest book
is I Have Nothing to Hide and 20 Other Myths
About Surveillance and Privacy.
It's really great having you on.
I appreciate your time.
Speaker 2: Thank you, David.
Great to be here.
Speaker 1: So let's start historically a little
bit if we can.
Was there sort of a surveillance state before
9/11 and the Patriot Act and the bulk surveillance
that we've learned about over the last decade
or so?
What was there an apparatus that predated
that and to what extent?
Speaker 2: There has always been a surveillance
apparatus in the United States and the justification
for it remains the same.
It's largely based on the government's theory
that we need to be monitored to protect national
security.
And I think what we've seen with the events
of 9/11, but also as the digital age has really
taken over our lives, we've seen that surveillance
apparatus on steroids in effect.
And the ways that we can be monitored are
just about as many as one can imagine.
And we're seeing so many levels of creativity
to do that, spying on children, to just invading
all aspects of our daily lives.
Speaker 1: Let's talk about some of the methods,
I guess, because people may not be familiar
with all of them.
I think metadata is a term that many more
people now are familiar with maybe than they
used to be in this concept of, well, even
without the content of a phone call, a list
of the numbers you've interacted with, who
can be very revealing and invasive when it
when it comes to observing your activities.
But can you talk a little bit about the breadth
of these techniques and technologies that
are in place?
Speaker 2: An easy way to look at the extent
to which we are monitored is to think of the
gold rush of the early days of this nation.
We're in a data rush right now, and data represents
essentially the crude oil that fuels our digital
economy.
So every time you log on, we have third party.
We have data aggregators, which is more than
a two hundred million dollar billion dollar
business in this country.
So if you think of it as your personal information
is like nuggets of gold that others want to
reap, collect as much as they can, essentially
without the laws, sort of like the property
laws that didn't exist when we had the the
early gold rush.
Our legislators have not kept up with tech
advances so that Facebook, for example, just
announced that it was putting the pause on
developing an app, an Instagram type app for
kids right up, which really habituate to not
only young kids to become loyal users of that
app, but it allows third parties to gather
personal information.
It may be just what sites they visit, what
preferences they have when they purchase something
online, or when they ask their parents to
buy something.
Each of those kernels, when put together,
can give a really accurate profile of our
lives.
And you mentioned made it metadata.
Well, metadata is defined very loosely as
information about information.
So it's sort of when a photo might have been
taken.
It's kind of embedded in all of the documents
that we get online that when captured in large
quantities and having algorithms applied to
search for patterns in that can really tell
a lot about who we are.
For example, if I went to a cancer doctor
five times in one week or an abortion provider,
those that information is then sold to others,
including government agencies, but largely
marketers and for profit entities who then
design ads to target us to buy more of a similar
product or to send us ads about cancer treatments
and medications.
The problem is when you get faulty algorithms,
as we so often do, and one example was drone
strikes that this country launched in Afghanistan
and other countries from 2006 on, there were
flawed algorithms, which means that in that
case there were lethal consequences.
People who really shouldn't have been on a
terrorist watch list, for example, may have
been killed in drone strikes, innocent individuals.
Speaker 1: Right.
There's kind of two layers on which we could
talk about the security aspect of the surveillance
state.
One would be, does it make us safer?
And if it did, we could then have a debate
about the tradeoffs and whether that's worthwhile.
So maybe we can start with the first piece.
Do we know that these techniques put in place
starting around 9/11 and going forward?
Does this increase safety in any measurable
way?
Speaker 2: There's been no evidence to prove
that it does increase safety.
And that's really a tragedy because I think
millions of Americans may think they're doing
the right thing by saying, I have nothing
to hide.
You can have my data.
But I think it was the Navy War College issued
a report years ago saying that they had analyzed
so-called threats of terrorists and found
that the measures put in place after 9/11,
which really cut back on a lot of our liberties
and certain constitutional rights that we
take for granted, they found no evidence that
it made us safer in any instance.
And I think the problem is most people don't
know that it's not publicized because in addition
to bolstering the claim that it does make
us safer, what it ultimately does is hand
over information that gives more control to
those in charge, and that means less autonomy
in our personal lives and more control by
others.
Speaker 1: Now, if it let's talk about I have
nothing to hide, maybe maybe a little bit.
A few years ago, I mean, that seemed pretty
reasonable to me.
You know, my my feeling was, yeah, I get that
there may be people who know more about me
than I would willingly give up, but I don't
have any particular reason to worry about
this because I don't have anything to hide.
And then I read about over criminalization
about how sometimes you may not think you
have anything to hide, but you may inadvertently
have done something or interacted with someone
who does maybe have something to hide and
then all of the other pernicious ways in which
this can be used.
What's the best sort of argument against that
idea of I really don't care, I don't have
anything to hide?
Speaker 2: I think a fundamental argument
against that is that people need to realize
the importance that privacy has played in
this society.
For example, during the AIDS epidemic, a lot
of health care providers hotlines realize
that in order to help quell the spread of
HIV, they would need to offer anonymous reporting
or anonymous testing.
And that's true in so many other segments.
So, for example, a woman who has been the
victim of spousal abuse has to know if she's
going to come forward to seek help, that she
can do so anonymously or privately.
And there are different levels of how you
shield one's identity, but that pertains to
whistleblowing in government to encourage
people to come forward when they see malfeasance
in the institutions in which we put our trust.
So I think you have to start at privacy plays
an essential part in society, and then you
have to realize that if you're willing to
hand over your entire life to the government,
we do so because we trust the government.
And I think that's a wonderful premise on
which to base a democracy.
But we have seen, in fact, that we cannot
always trust our leaders, that self-interest
or other factors may lead them to abuse our
information or very often just due to a casual
mistake.
My name may be confused with a similar name.
I may be mixed up with someone who did commit
a crime, for example, but because of the databases
that all of our information is stored in contain
so many errors, often just sloppy data entries,
that there have been so many cases of people
caught up in a crime that had nothing to do
with their lives and they were falsely prosecuted.
It also shows that if the government doesn't
like what you say, if you're a dissident or
just an outspoken individual who criticizes
a corporate policy, for example, or government
policy, they can target you and find just
about any reason among the many antiquated
laws that are on our books to go after you.
Speaker 1: Yeah, that I just I'm almost done
reading this new book, The Perfect Police
State, about China and the persecution of
of the wigger population.
Is there a spectrum in the sense of it?
It seems in terms of surveillance, China is
very much on one end.
What's on the other end?
And where on that spectrum is, is the United
States?
In your assessment,
Speaker 2: that's an excellent question.
We do look to China as an example of the extreme
and what we as a purported democracy would
never want to be, where, for example, I just
have to say they have a system that is being
used in some parts of China where you're under
such constant surveillance that if you jaywalk,
for example, or if you don't pick up after
your dog points are deducted.
Yes.
And that can reflect the electricity.
You get access to social services on the other
extreme.
And that's a great question, because I can't
really think of a nation on so many of our
partners in the so-called five eyes, New Zealand,
Canada, the UK have sort of rings of surveillance
everywhere.
It's become the norm and we're becoming conditioned
to just accept that.
But I would imagine there are probably countries
in Scandinavia or countries maybe in Latin
America, South America, where the technology
in some of those countries may not be as sophisticated
as what we have here with our robust economy.
So I would imagine that in countries without
that kind of surveillance accessibility, you
don't have the digital surveillance we have
here.
Speaker 1: And so where is the US on this
spectrum right now in your assessment?
Speaker 2: I think the U.S. is pretty high
up there with England, for example, as basically
having the equivalent of these what we call
rings of steel, the circles of surveillance
cameras, closed circuit TV.
But we have that built into our economy so
that as simple as getting a cup of coffee
may have a loyalty card where they track the
numbers of coffees that you buy, but they
also track more your credit card number, which
is linked to other data.
I think that the US is in a race to perfect
total information awareness, the collection
and with the entry of 5G, where more things
will be even connected and when they're Internet
connected, that provides near perfect access
to our data.
Speaker 1: I wonder, let me see how I can
kind of frame this up.
I wonder if there's a degree of inevitability
to this because of the direction, not from
a law enforcement standpoint, but from a sociocultural
technology standpoint.
If there is a degree of inevitability to some
of this and I'll give you like one example
and then we can talk about it, the entire
literature now around longevity and living
longer, healthier lives and nanomedicine and
customized.
And it's mostly all premised on having much
more data, not only about you as an individual,
but data about how you compare to others and
what sort of diet or supplements or treatments
or whatever the case may be.
Good for you specifically.
There's really no way it seems to do this
stuff without many more parties having access
not only to our individual data, but to everybody
in some sense.
And for the most part, I mean, in some kind
of like general sense, a lot of that stuff
sounds kind of interesting, like it would
be great to know what exact diet or what exact
preventive treatment.
So is there some inevitability to this that
is going to be hard to restrict at all?
Speaker 2: I think that's absolutely right.
First we have convenience, then we have the
kind of addictive quality that these devices
have and they're created, in effect, just
like video games to be addictive.
Yeah, but there are, as with all technology,
so many positive benefits, as you mentioned.
And I think the trick is harnessing those,
but also having an educated public that is
able to realize when they should have the
option of saying, I don't wish to share that.
And I think the problem that we're having
and why I wrote this book sort of is a primer
so people can get a sense of the different
areas that were impacted by is we need to
first our legislators have to be more educated
about technology.
They're woefully behind the advancements.
And that's a problem because they can't craft
laws that keep pace with new technologies
that are emerging daily and new applications.
So I think if we have a program where we educate
kids the first time they learn to type on
a keyboard what the perils are and what the
benefits are and really develop a healthy
course in school that parents also participate
in in digital hygiene, we would not, for example,
let a stranger walk into our bedroom every
night and use our toothbrush or just make
themselves at.
Downstairs and that's in effect what we're
doing and what young kids are doing without
that education.
So I think you have to educate the public
and our leaders to the degree that they are
able to say we need to build in privacy, for
example, into our devices or the software
has to be better tested before it's put on
the marketplace to ensure that adequate privacy
protections are built into their infrastructure.
Speaker 1: Last thing I want to touch on with
you, if someone right now is makes it a priority
to prevent themselves from being tracked,
watched, monitored, surveilled, et cetera,
you Google this and you see things like turn
off microphone access for your Facebook app
on your phone.
Right.
Very, very narrow and specific thing.
All the way to don't use banks or credit cards,
which for the average participant in the modern
economy is not at all sort of practical.
To what degree is it possible to to really
not be tracked right now, regardless of how
aggressively you're willing to adopt these
things?
Or to some degree, if you're sort of like
living on the grid?
It's quite difficult at this point in time.
Speaker 2: It's super difficult.
One would have to literally not use a credit
card, stay off online searches.
Yeah.
And and and I think what's daunting to most
people, and I get it, is that, you know, encrypting
for those who are reporters or journalists
who have to protect confidential sources,
there are wonderful measures in place that
they can use.
It becomes more difficult for the average
citizen to use all of those.
But there are basic things like not using
the same password over changing it, using
a sentence instead of your pets name.
There are basic things that aren't that hard,
enabling two factor authentication.
For example, when you log into accounts, keep
down the number of apps that you have.
They're really portals unless they come directly
from the manufacturer.
Don't download download things from online.
There are measures you can take to reduce
the amount of surveillance.
I think it's unrealistic to say you can stop
it entirely unless you go off the grid.
Speaker 1: Yeah, yeah.
The book is I Have Nothing to Hide and 20
other myths about surveillance and privacy.
We've been speaking with the book's author,
New York City based attorney Heidi Bogosian.
Such a pleasure having you on.
I really appreciate your time today.
Speaker 2: Thank you, David.